you're not ready at 18 to make a
decision about your [ __ ] life man
yeah kind of Janaka regulations need to
make a decision about your [ __ ] life
man you're not really keen to make a
decision about your life why do we
become parents and push our children to
[ __ ] make a decision at 18 or even 20
nobody in this room I know you're an
engineering Amelia it's not anybody it
but and nobody knows at 20 what the [ __ ]
they really want to do and then one day
you raise your [ __ ] hand and you're
in there two years and you go on TV and
you see some guy putting [ __ ]
cigarettes up his ass I'll be like you
know what I dreamt that as a child I'm
gonna do that and now but now you're
stuck right you got a loan you got your
mom proud of you should cut the clip
side you made it to five bagger kappa
you know and now you graduated now what
bro yeah why are you going to a job that
you really don't want to do you just
want to consider it's on your ass go and
make ten dollars a figure right that's
all you want to do it your [ __ ] life
man but no you get this job that'll
start to drinking now you mean a
check-in you haven't you knock her up
and you have a kid but guess what she's
one of those chicks and you're knocked
up it's like two tanks are in her ass
now now you gotta walk around with this
[ __ ] monster and that with a job you
hate with a kid with uglier than you are
cuz now you got your wife it's a [ __ ]
night man you wake up one day it's
already in you like what the [ __ ] did I
do and there's a path that starts
everything that's the drinking the drugs
the divorce you unhappy you haven't met
not even a midlife crisis you don't even
want to do your [ __ ] job no more man
this isn't what you want to do in the
first place but you got yourself in such
a big [ __ ] hole with that fat [ __ ]
the kid in the [ __ ] house with the
one because America soldier is America
soldiers and you know I bought it I
bought it when I came out of prison I'm
like that said I'm gonna be a good boy
and I'm gonna get a job and be a roofing
this the middle of Saturday I'm all the
world and there was a sudden I guess I
gotta do laundry and shovel and do
that's my life till I'm 16 mind you give
me a [ __ ] watch and and this was the
way I thought like I was like that what
am I supposed to tell people that I went
to college and wasted my time
this is a waste of time but it took me
$200,000 to really figure out what I
want to do in life which was push dagger
taught my [ __ ] so you know yeah
we are not we're not ready and everybody
had you know a who else's sat in this
chair what's the skinny girl I was a
doctor who was that Ashley huh final
Ashley
yeah skinny chick she's a CA also opens
up for a boy or actually bought him
Carly [ __ ] okay yeah that one who
else was a [ __ ] doctor I came in here
something like that and quit or somebody
else had come in here last couple of
years that was docked and said deter I
didn't want to do in the middle you know
it you you forced society forces you
then we drink it's a different type of
cocaine John wasn't here like Johnny and
you go oh so I'm gonna leave my doctor
patient could be I got a hit for him you
know when you take an even more
impressive warm person yeah that's
residency and all them your patients and
then take that leap and I think it's
even harder your patients dying he's not
cheering for you
I'm dying over you [ __ ] but it's
it's always that decision it killed me
yeah I didn't know how do you think I
want to [ __ ] play that dumb [ __ ] if I
would have known this was it if I would
have known this was it when I was and I
started late dog I saw there 28 the sons
and that's [ __ ] late Jack I was long
in the tooth did everyone say to you
something
what are you doing with károly the thing
that my least favorite thing that people
say is it works isn't supposed to be fun
you're not supposed to have fun at work
and I'd like it just seems like maybe an
engineer in places like that's what
they'd say look comedy is great but what
like works not too fun well I didn't
tell anybody at work that I did stand-up
just because I like keeping my world set
so smart I'm terrible yeah just and I
don't want them to think that I'm the
funny like I'm conversationally funny
you know I'm not off-the-wall I'm not
going to be doing the different types of
comics you know I'd want to have a
conversation with somebody so I hate I
would hate if somebody at my job knew I
did stand-up and there's expecting joke
for me it's the copy machine or like a
when can I come see I don't I don't like
that that was good move yeah well I just
only I know how people are so I just
kept my rule and I didn't want them to
think that my work was being affected by
what I do outside of my job like I
didn't want my father to think comedies
affecting my work because it's not can
you off on Saturdays and Sundays yeah
off on setters in some days and then
stand up as a night game so you know I
get off in all weekends at that point
like lawyerly not because that came
later me getting past the school came
yeah and came home later call your mom
is got past the first I've told you look
at these benchmarks for us don't mean
anything to my parents you know like
they don't know clarify they don't know
the Comedy Store names on the wall they
don't know how important that every
watched on TV yeah they seemed like some
late-night sets and they've seen me like
I wasn't that Tina Fey movie so like
then when to the theaters and saw that
and what do they think I think my mom is
love I took my mom at the premiere
just you got to take your mom so I take
you got a meeting to say you know
everybody like Margot Robbie
she was starstruck and she loved it um
but my dad is old-school like he still
talked about on two days ago she was
like your dad's worried about you like
what are you gonna do your life what are
you gonna do like I'm still [ __ ]
around here you know like my dad only
understands money and sing what's your
bed before he's an engineer installing
as well that's our coal mine man yeah
let me do BRE me dude
yeah he's my guy he's he's in cm he
works at the one in Bellevue no that's
what I figured but he knows what I can
be so that's what frustration shall do
we watch him expand them enough you know
what's so funny is like dad loves Steve
Martin this his favorite comic but he
just wants his kids to have nothing to
do with like Afghans or my pension from
Afghanistan they don't want they love
art but they don't want their kids to
make a career out of it they want them
to be doctors lawyers and all that stuff
so yeah the consumer arts but they like
we don't want you to do that for a
living
did your parents move from Afghanistan
yeah yeah I got like that ever since I
was like I kid I was in first generation
or anything but I would always get
taught in like Hebrew school and stuff
like that like Jewish kids like the
Jewish families but they were it was
huge
when we first moved here education all
that like for those like probably
similar reasons while your parents is
just like they they're working so hard
and they see like that's the only real
way to guarantee I understand it oh yeah
like you know I've got my own path and
I'm trying to go down but I understand
where they're coming from just let that
immigrant mentality cuz yeah mm-hm
I'm doing what they weren't they
couldn't afford to do when you come from
another place you got to plant your
roots yeah you got it you're not gonna
be a mime when you come from IBM's game
and you're in America you've got to be
an engineer you've got to be these
things to just plant your roots here and
then their kids me I can do calm I mean
I'm fortunate enough to be able to do
comedy but they didn't have that luxury
so that's why it's so foreign for them I
think